let's talk about Star Wars for a second
all right JJ Abrams Star Wars V is going
to come out what is the actual release
date for that I think it's on December
some time to send right now this has got
to be the year of the nerd I mean this
is your expertise people are losing
their minds over this movie yes because
it looks like he's gonna do a real good
job with it yeah and I mean you know
we've been burned a couple times before
and so to see a guy who you know is so
invested in making the effects look good
and making everything look real and you
know story good a story good and and
bringing in you know at the end of the
trailer with you know Harrison Ford you
know just the Chewie we're home it's
like people must have lost their minds
nerds around the world when they saw
Harrison Ford say that line with that
way they lost their minds yeah they did
because it's it's like you know it's a
piece of your childhood being reflected
back to you and Harrison Ford he's been
on the Nerdist podcast before and he's
I'm sure he's been on your show before
yeah he's uh he's he's a trick you know
like he kind of does this character of
like I'm cranky but I think part of him
is just cranky yeah cuz I was i
moderated a panel with him at comic-con
in San Diego and he was just kind of up
there being being Harrison Ford and the
first guy gets up to ask a question and
he's really nervous like I was before a
longtime fan so what what would what
would Han Solo say if he met Indiana
Jones and then Harrison Ford who clearly
was not enthused with the question just
goes hello
[Laughter]
now fair answer some people have pointed
out that in the trailer Harrison Ford's
character Han Solo has clearly aged yeah
2530 years but that he's with Chewbacca
who hasn't aged yeah and that seemed
like there are people actually talking
about that like why hasn't Chewbacca
aged and then other people saying
because Chewbacca species doesn't age at
the same rate that's the level that
we're talking about yes so hair plugs
Chewbacca said hair plugs how to work
done yeah
those drinks Rogaine every now but there
was a there was some picture floating
around reddit that was phenomenal it was
like you know what Chewbacca looks like
and it was that still of what we have
this is the that's a very good
observation not a the face does tend to
sag later
so I guess ultimately Harry of Harry and
the Hendersons was really old Chewbacca
right basically hey thanks for watching
be sure to click subscribe to see even
more great Conan clips you may now
return to your pirated movies and creepy
Japanese pornography